it's great to welcome to the program
today Ian Haney Lopez who is a
constitutional law professor at the
University of California Berkeley and
also author of the book merged left
fusing race and class winning elections
and saving America it's so great to have
you on today thank you it's really great
to join you so the the angle I'm very
interested in is that of really thinking
about how to win because one of the
areas where I've been a bit disaffected
lately with my own movement the
progressive movement in which you know I
consider myself a member is that
sometimes I think we may miss the forest
for the trees
when it comes to how to win and you talk
very interestingly about the right and
wrong way to deal with race in politics
and sometimes the arguments that are
made are I feel overly simplistic like
identity politics is bad or good versus
actually a discussion of what we mean by
that and how something as important to
identity as race should be discussed so
maybe to start lay out the panorama as
you see it of how some of these issues
are being discussed in politics and how
you would maybe want to see that changed
so I think the number one thing to start
with there is the idea that race is
being used as a wedge issue to divide
Americans and more particularly to
divide a Democratic constituency that
used to include the white working-class
african-americans and white liberals
everybody understands that race is being
used as a wedge issue but the left today
is badly divided in how to respond the
more centrist position though this is a
position that's also adopted by economic
populist like Bernie Sanders is to focus
on winning over white voters and to
understand or to believe that talking
about race will alienate white voters
and so to a duck as a racial strategy
the tactic of not talking about race at
all so all the sort of amongst interest
Democrats and among some some radical
economic populist there's a tendency to
go colorblind to emphasize economic
issues and to downplay the centrality of
race that's on one side on the other
side especially among racial justice
activists you have a very strong sense
that we need to talk about race we need
to talk about it both in terms of the
systemic violence by government against
communities of color violence that's
evident in mass incarceration and over
policing and mass deportation ice
enforcement but also in the consistent
neglect of communities of color so we
need to address it and we need to
address as well frontally and head-on
the use of race as as a wedge issue in
politics that's the that's the divide
both camps are thinking about how to
deal with race and they're coming up
with very different solutions ignore it
and hope you can change the conversation
or attack it head-on so there's one I'll
call it a proposed solution that I read
about frequently and I want to see
whether you think it it really is sort
of up to the challenge of dealing with
this issue in a productive way which is
talk about race but always make it a
race class narrative like that's that's
the prescription that's how you do it
you talk about class understanding that
race is part of it you meld them
together you don't alienate anybody does
that shake how do you how would you
analyze that idea so so that's the idea
that I sort of come to a number of years
ago and worked on with unions and then
ultimately put together a research
project the race class narrative project
using communication specialists and
pollsters and and here's the core idea
and I and I really want to make this
point as shortly as I can this is not a
typical race plus class we should do
both type move this is a paradigm change
in how we think about the relationship
between race and class it's a paradigm
change because what it's saying is race
and class
are not in the United States separate
they're completely dependent on each
other or to put that more concretely in
the class war that the rich are winning
their number-one weapon is racial
division the rich are siphoning more and
more wealth to themselves because
they've been successful in dividing us
along race lines and this has very clear
implications if you want to if you want
economic populism and if you want racial
justice because what it says is if you
want economic populism you have to fight
race as a do as a tactic for dividing
American voters and what it says is if
you want racial justice you have to
fight racial division you have to make
it clear to rights that they have their
own pragmatic interest in opposing
racial division so that rights will
understand that they have their own
pragmatic interest in supporting racial
justice I'm reminded of the sort of
status quo that exists in much of the
agricultural world that deals with
immigration where we've seen large
corporations that benefit from both
documented and undocumented immigrant
labor very successfully convinced a lot
of Americans that this is really about
our brown people stealing your jobs and
that seems to me to have been a very
effective way of taking the attention
off of the fact that these corporations
want to pay the lowest possible wages
even if they are not fair wages that
these corporations disproportionately
take advantage with very little
consequence of undocumented immigrant
labor because those rules are often
ignored by the government as priorities
is that an example of how this is being
weaponized in a sense as you described
you know it's a really great example
because it illustrates two distinct
phenomenon we have to keep both in mind
one way to think about the connections
between race and class is to think about
the way in which economic exploitation
of people of color has been the
foundation for this country so you can
think about it as the racialization of
Native Americans as inferior as an
excuse to take land or the racialization
of people from Africa as black as an
excuse for slavery and so on through
manifest destiny and through today's
exploitation of immigrant labor and
especially undocumented immigrant labor
this is a story that says race and class
focus on what's happening to communities
of color in the way they're economically
exploited a very very important story
but here's the point don't stop there
the race and class are fused throughout
the American economy and as importantly
throughout the American government which
regulates the economy and this is the
other part of the story that you
surfaced not only are corporations that
explored exploiting brown and black and
Asian people but they're also turning
around and saying to White's the cause
of economic misery in your life are
these undeserving threatening others
blame them hate government because
government supposedly cares more about
them than it does about you you're on
your own and a buy a gun and B trust the
marketplace because through hard work
you'll take care of yourself and if you
fail you alone are responsible and what
this means is that the entire economy
the entire government the way government
is captured by the rich is also a
function of racial narratives in our
political sphere in our culture this is
incredibly important racing class is not
just a story about what's happening to
communities of color it's a story about
what's happening to the United States as
a whole it's a story about what has
happened to us over the last 50 years
we've seen the greatest transfer of
wealth upward from all of us into the
economic stratosphere that we've seen in
a century
why because many Americans working
to vote their racial fears you cannot
understand surging economic inequality
that impoverishes almost all of us
including whites without focusing on the
way in which race has been used as the
principal weapon against all of us yes
so that gets to trump in 2016 and I
should be interested in hearing your
thoughts about how you know in the
post-mortems of what happened there have
been all sorts of different analyses
that purport to know what it was that
allowed Donald Trump to win now
one merely mathematical point is when
you're talking about about 70,000 votes
in three states that could have flipped
it we want to be careful about pointing
to any one thing because there's
probably 30 different things that could
have made a seventy thousand vote
difference but what I want to focus in
on with you is the fear of losing status
that was in the minds of many voters who
did ultimately vote for Trump how does
that tie into the race class analysis
Trump wins overwhelmingly because of his
success and appealing to racial
resentment and racial anxiety but we
should be clear Trump was not the
originator of that strategy that's a
fifty-year-old strategy Republicans have
been trying that since 1964 right and
especially since 1970 it has been their
principal route to building popular
support to winning elections so when we
look at Mitt Romney's numbers 90 percent
of Mitt Romney support came from white
voters same with with Donald Trump 3 out
of 5 rights voted for Mitt Romney saying
with Donald Trump ninety-eight percent
of Republican elected officials are
white similar numbers under Trump Donald
Trump pushes more aggressively a
strategy that has been in place and has
been working for the Republicans for 50
years not since 1964 has a Democratic
candidate for president won a majority
of the white vote this is very
very much about race but it's also
important to pause and say that doesn't
mean this isn't about class there's art
of it
this debate is a trace or is a class for
many people afraid of losing status they
have lost status they have lost position
their lives are in peril many whites are
in trouble they're under tremendous
stress right this is the sort of
research that talks now about deaths of
despair suicide violence drug addiction
like most of us many whites are under
tremendous pressure and what's happening
is that the Republicans have created
that pressure by siphoning wealth up
into the up to the very rich but they've
also turned around and said you know why
your life is in such danger it's because
of people of color they're coming in
they're flooding the country they're
taking what they don't deserve and
they're also violent and they don't
respect life the way we do right
this is a race story to provide a frame
to interpret economic hardship I want to
be very clear economic hardship is not
the main thing here many people like
Robert Rice start by saying economic
hardship Verte first then people look
for someone to blame that's not the
history dog whistling starts and is
tremendously successful at a time in
1970 1972 when most working-class whites
were doing remarkably well race has its
own independent power but race and class
combined in a vicious circle the more
people vote their racial fears the more
they elect politicians who serve the
plutocrats the more those politicians
turn around and rig the system to help
very rich and beggar the rest of us the
more they feel stressed and look for
someone to blame and are encouraged to
use race as the focus of their hatred
and their anxiety it becomes a vicious
circle and no one better embodies that
than Donald Trump the last thing I want
to touch on and we have sort of limited
time left is I want to get your thoughts
on the identity politics debate that it
is sort of existing on the Left I'll
give you my sort of twenty second
position which is I am against the use
of identity as a cudgel as a basis on
which to silence someone as a basis on
which to disqualify somebody etc but I
do believe that one's identity gives
insight into what it is like to
experience the world through that
identity and so we should want that we
should welcome that and we should listen
to it that's where I kind of land on it
I don't know if that is a coherent
strategy for electoral politics however
oh I think it is and I would just extend
it further and I would say it's always
identity politics more than anything
else political scientists and democratic
realists understand people are voting in
terms of a series of questions Who am I
in this society who are my friends who
threatens me who can I work with those
are questions of identity and we are all
thinking in those terms so the problem
with the term like identity politics is
when it's applied to some groups but not
to others we should all be thinking that
all of us are operating organizing
voting in terms of identity and what
that means is we need to create the sort
of identity that includes an awful lot
of us a super majority of us because
although with a bigger we only with an
inclusive identity that takes identity
seriously can we actually create the
wave election that we need to change the
direction in this country and this is
where that race class fusion becomes so
important because what it says is all of
us want to take care of our families all
of us want a world in which we're
welcome and respected and safe but some
people are trying to divide us let's
come together over those lines of
division let's come together
specifically across racial lines because
when we come together and understand
we're all in this together
then and only then can we build a
political power to really change this
country's direction and that's going to
be good for all our families whether
were white black or brown
everybody's helped when we realize all
of our fates are linked very very
interesting we've been speaking with Ian
Haney Lopez who is a constitutional law
professor the book merged left fusing
race and class winning elections and
saving America thank you so much for
talking to me today I really appreciate
your time thanks so much I really
appreciate the conversation